and I don't want to like spoil it but I
feel like we were gonna want a bio
trekker bio trackers are for scrubs and
noobs and we are not it better than you
did Bob I agree with that one
house where tracker defeated the enemy
watch here over here and we'll file
flashlights you guys see this I don't
think we need to kill him if you just
stun them with that they'll never move
again watch your pet weight fall in the
pit if you come in position and get the
one on the right I'm going to start
charging now and I'm gonna run at them
[Laughter]
there's one around the corner here above
you we need you as a third all right all
right I'm in position no no actually all
three of us they're charging now and run
at them 100% health except for one of us
there's three of us and six of them we
don't want to eat basically perfect
which ones might actually [ __ ] love
this is the best game ever
I will move in
[Applause]
into the fray I can't believe that
didn't go well for us
I went to get him and I went up on this
tiny lip of the steps and then it
dropped and made noise ha God is clear
now nice white I'm pretty sure this is
what the developers intended I have the
Sun now as well oh yes brother would
we'll ever see again a three star system
alright texted interesting interesting
just get this going
you guys ready you guys didn't open this
locker
I'm not surprised now maybe you [ __ ]
god damn it what is it what you get the
fog blowers I got a big flashlight wait
wait I gotta go get mine I I dropped my
not for the seafoam I'm sorry brothers
I'm sorry brothers what have you done I
have it I have it
what's the darksouls thing with the
praise the sun emote was that good
you're gonna put your hands on a white
yeah raise the Sun Johnny cooperation
okay let's do it
I'm not even pulling a gun out my
flashlight is my weapon
[ __ ] century right here you know what
friend could you stand in the circle
what's I quote you obviously thank you
where is that
last one or the death pile [ __ ] through
the death pile of garbage brothers I
should okay behind me smart I'm a not
smart I'm not in the opposite of that
oh there's one up top where's this other
Oh be crazy
you got it boys all right it's scanned
in hindsight would seem that the drafts
are in a foul position I don't like the
way that you do things I assumed they
would be ones weak from behind oh no I'm
gonna go down boys no but I'm not down
oh hell that's enough ye of little
health you have too much wench you
distraction and I came up from the rear
let's see how [ __ ] em oh [ __ ] century
sure let's go
but flashlight lodge everyone
flashlights already
oh no we're good from behind
no really yes lots of them for mine
alright think we're saved yeah yeah
we're safe if anyone wants to shoot in
my direction but not me but me be
probably helpful that'd be probably
really helpful
that's what mallets are for brother okay
everything's fine
alright so clear so try my light towards
you I can't see interesting reaction to
a tiny dude the room there's room has
listen I just walked out my light was
out I saw four glowy's all your dick
should be instead exactly who said it
wasn't you can both can exist
simultaneously now if your dick was out
you'd have take out energy you've got
yeah he got heavily zipped energy right
now bro yeah fellas there seems to be
some sort of thick air down here but
help know how thick does your light
penetrate oh it's very far 0h but
there's one freaking out wait I don't
know if we're I don't know if we're
doing that anymore I think you can give
up on the game chill out a little bed
the whole still walking around killing
things
guys I have a for use medpac epic where
where am i coming down too late I'm
getting up okay well you know the smell
Mel's kids you have no dude look how
much health you have compared to
everyone else look out you're basically
alive oh yeah why are you guys so long
okay interesting interesting interesting
that you're saying that in the wrong
voices want you to know
no new information we have two security
doors that aren't alarm and one that is
alarm which ones wait I'm assuming it
would be smart to do that alarm door
while these doors are shut
probably smart coward would say the SIS
got ammo packs oh my god well we gotta
go ahead with the doors they have 69 on
the profit yeah obviously we were smart
we do alarmed or first but I think we're
dumb I think we do this one Mike you
specimen mo you got lots of ammo bro 6
percent and 23 percent yeah don't move
mark on this door first that feels like
the good call - not if we don't open oh
it's a great weight impression how did
that turn it to a roast of weight I was
just jealous doing my own weight
straight down over these guys before
there are many to numerous ma but our
hammers are strong and my peepee large
and I am fully unzipped so you're making
great statements but walking in the
opposite direction office Wade you have
this return yes got some bad guys over
here it's ok it's only look at how angry
they are from that [ __ ] yeah I'm working
on it guys already all right I'll get
the third one I'll start charging up
from here
this is a pro-gamer move about to be
executed
wait it's going down man wait as Isis
righteous timber okay what stroke no one
struck it wait wait don't wait you
excites five and stop moving one more
one more one more
it's fine that you stupid considering
how I might just grab the house yeah I
have seafoam grenades oh ah brothers no
sakkath of [ __ ] you be a dangus I do see
it watch what happened what did you did
what do you eight who boot what did you
did oh hey come to me friends look at
this cool door over here it's fine oh
god oh god
[Laughter]
what what is it what does that mean it's
a big one that shoots multiple things as
we hit it where is it but it shoots
things at me will it shoots all the
yellow things coming off of it just keep
adding it it's still alive it's very
strong smashing head bro I didn't miss a
single shot alright fair enough can't
believe I just have my flashlight
staring them in the face and then going
I am very worried that
we will have to do a reactor test
sequence and we're like blowing all our
ammo are you jacksepticeye yeah [ __ ]
idiot we are we smacking this big boy
right there's another one over here
isn't there are they both big yeah
they're both big which probably
multi-team this fellow yeah well we can
kill one without alerting the other if
we all know we just wait can we stand
okay that is my question the control key
on your key working up to this thing
charge charge now three two oh stop stop
cancel charge now okay three two one
okay look at Wade why are you scratching
what I'm trying to be stealthy watch out
for that Tongass alright he did good job
Wow probably safe in here now I'm gonna
just run around a little bit not see
foam grenades nice neat my dog just went
the other room and took a poop just came
wandering back in from the hallway and
was like hey [ __ ] took a [ __ ] alright
I'm in the [ __ ] of the Giants we're
not in anywhere near you I'm gonna start
charging on the big dude everyone run
over here what what I serve this a bit
it's a bit so we're just avoiding this
do things good I love your real life if
you don't do it enough thank you funny
enough to draw that out of you more
often trouble down there friend I both
flashed him and then box down here I
don't what are we going for it was we
already knows in 70 do we go the wrong
way to the [ __ ] can you guys stop
doing that in the middle of what I was
doing
can't they come out of the zone we were
just in door there so we could seafoam
it up wow wow wow this one yes
Wow never stop swelling please God never
should I put this on the other side of
the door then mouth wide yeah Wow
do what you want be ouch man oh wow what
the [ __ ] is happening you sound like a
smash don't catch you
cartoon cat judge you [ __ ] you forget
lasagna you just don't know how to get
out of it just getting ready right away
no foreplay at all let's do this boy Rob
they're coming through that way I can't
see cuz the funds is right in front of
my face oby got a big old pyrenees fan
over here it's just too big Wow
no they want us hello that was quick
Bosh male oh [ __ ] I hear them I see them
in the fog wow we should have deep fog
God thank you for the new [ __ ] that
really actually helps quite a lot over
here boys over here boys I mean over
there boys quickly run around boys over
here boys oh god oh god I'm last oh we
got this boys all right done feel free
to shoot him what the [ __ ] now what the
[ __ ] what the hell was that
wait it's just like a helpless baby yeah
well well well feed me
and I hate it so much I still haven't
figured we're actually trying this time
I didn't shoot at anything I have the
exact same amount of bullets in my
kitchen see right there
he got probably six seven good kids
doors go off why are you surprised by
anything anymore wait I mean it's fine
guys stop freaking out
listen Oh another devil door boy looks
like that time we run that other bridge
yeah one more one more okay oh yeah
gamers oh yeah stragglers somewhere I
know mine you burn you up I see I see I
see thanks for shooting what a surprise
where'd that guy come from foam grenade
Mushmouth yeah we don't want 77 to 78
that doesn't sound like the way we want
to know 272 yeah 72 ever headed Weiss
sound happening oh hey but if we go back
here it's just one alarm or well I mean
it's probably multiple alarms this other
stand or over here does not have a yeah
there's no security in it all right yeah
maybe go through there just because
we're low on
no unch mouth oh hey Sean Bob you guys
might want to use your combat shotguns a
little bit I don't need to I'm hitting
from distance just thinking about stupid
suggestion I would ignore it thank you
for acknowledging how stupid it was oh
hey buds careful oh hey is that a big
boy oh god there's only one tool refill
in here I don't know if that's worth it
I'm just not worth it
I block this doors permanently open now
though we with them yeah that's so weird
it said it's out of range because it's
in zone 77 but I just queried its zone
73 what beat there must be a bug so we
don't go in this room I would not I say
screw this room we did just open this
door for the alarm during the other
place it's gonna be yeah yeah no it's
fine all right let's go where we go at
the devil door now all right boys that's
not good that you did that good yeah
does anyone have a turret right now baby
let's put it put it in a good one oh
this is a good run here this is why God
gave us sea foam and mallets I'm a sea
foam and uh huh yeah Betsy in my story
sounds a you go pin we're safe we are
safe
okay are we ready yeah there it go oh
there you go oh is it can this is what
it means to go even right now not doing
Ethan stuff it is it is just a
Dragonball Z reference it's not really I
didn't know you guys came up without all
my ass okay
are we knowing this sucks whoa oh boy
okay where's this other circle up top
I'm down
oh I'm down to [ __ ] I'm in a corner it
was horrible what's okay I can't hit
yourself just got killed by something
that didn't exist or wasn't visible
that's not a thing
so do you wait you got this I have 5%
ammo you got it yeah mallet now let's
swing forever yeah I'm down but I can
turn on my flashlight okay
oh can you Oh need out sounds like we're
to the came from behind
Oh dicks
[Music]